I'm going to talk about the new version
of whorfin language and Mathematica
which we released today version 11.3 and
I really just want to have some fun
playing with it because that's always
great once we've released a product to
actually try using it hopefully I won't
find any bugs we'll see people are very
welcome to ask questions and so on this
is being streamed on three different
networks and the questions are being
aggregated and I should see them fairly
quickly um alright let's let's get
started so let's see let's just check on
running the correct version yes eleven
point three there we go cooked just
today go here alright so what's new well
all kinds of stuff there's we can kind
of get some I wrote a blog post came out
today about some eleven point three and
has a little word cloud here that shows
kind of some of the highlighted
functions that are new eleven point
three but I'll go through a bunch of
these um always hard to know quite where
to start we can also get a summary by
looking in the help system that helps
system this help system um and look at
the bottom here where it says new
features and there'll be a big long list
of new features in eleven point three
all right well where should we start
maybe we can start machine learning
remains topical and we've been very
energetically pursuing all sorts of
things in machine learning they will
start there um so one of the things
we've been doing is to build a neural
net repository that's a collection of
[Music]
interesting neural nets we add to this
every week there's all kinds of
different things that all kinds of
different neural nets come out the idea
is to have them all in the format that
can immediately be computed with so
let's just pick this round and one I
don't know what this one does
but let's sum
okay let's see we seem to have to feed
it two kinds of things actually this
looks like alright so let's see how this
works so I just click net model there I
can reel in here now it will download
that net model from the cloud and now
this is a particular neural net and
there you can see the structure of the
neural net something new and 11:3 are
these nice little graphics of neural
nets and we can drill down and look at
the details of them if we want to we can
go ahead and start where we could
actually let's just try running it
that's some well I can just try the
example that was there so ah contains
the copied okay I see so those those
examples are too big to get with just
copying from a web page all right well
then let's let's use some let's get our
own our own pictures here so let's say
picture of I don't know what Washington
Monument how about that see whether we
can get that um and hopefully Washington
Monument historic site image okay there
we go and let's say let us ask for let's
get some picture how about um something
like van Gogh sunflowers so although
that oops oh my gosh there's a there's a
type of thumb it appears that there's a
type of sunflower called the van Gogh's
sunflowers kind of funny actually
van Gogh painting sunflowers let's do er
that is that a painting by Van Gogh
maybe we won't understand this no we
didn't all right let's just try how
about we just try let's try Monet
that's I just want to get a random a
random notable artwork here so I can oh
gosh there's lots of them so let's just
get some let's get the first five of
those and then let's say entity value
that call my image and eventually we're
gonna get a picture here um a painting
okay let's do that
see how many of them we have oh we have
all of them alright well there's a nice
there's a nice impressionist type
painting all right let's close this up
let's go back up here and um let's let's
now take this and actually something
which was which was new in 11.2 was the
imagery style function so we could
actually see how that works
I'm just running that there could do
imagery style on this oops the UM
imagery style on this and we could say
restyle that picture according to this
this is there we go so that was a nice
fast restyling not very high resolution
we could let's if we wanted to let's try
running this network which has a content
and a style so there we go and let's say
we have something that says content and
then we'd say the Washington Monument
picture and then we would say style and
then we'd say this and that will then
run this raw network um I just got from
the knurl that repository at least if I
could um to get the syntax right there
we go it'll just run this raw neural
Nets um on that particular pair of
images now if we wanted to just for fun
let's see what happens if we just take
this Network and we just do a net take
of that comma let's say 10 so that can
ah okay and so I want to go layers 7
through 10 so that can work ah I see
okay fair enough
oh this is the
this net model I think this network is a
graph and so it might be a little bit
trickier to chop out two pieces of that
graph I would have to go in here let's
take a look here and I would have to go
and figure out okay so that's called
decoder and I would say I would go from
Y as little tricky so I'd have to go in
here okay that's that's the internal
structure of this network um it's
interesting to see that here what what
is that that's a replication layer okay
so I wonder what happens if I would try
and say net take V underscore norm
underscore to see what that does
I don't know whether this will work but
let's say um that will be the name of a
layer um so I can just take that out no
it won't let me do that
what I wanted to do was to just put a
tap in the snow on that at that position
and and take a look at what this is
doing there but looks like I'm not I'm
not going to be in luck doing that but
it's kind of interesting to see and
maybe we can try a simpler you're on
that's all kinds of things here um so
what one of the things that happened was
in neural nets is that oh look there's
the even things that are specific okay
this is an apple to Orange translation
Network we could probably try running
the Apple to orange Network on
[Music]
see there's the Apple to orange Network
now we can pull it in here um okay it's
gonna it's taking a while to download
the Train Network okay there it is
okay so now this network we could just
go ahead and run that on an image so we
could rather bizarrely run that on for
example let's try running it on this
image here
and okay no know exactly what it did to
that image maybe we should try picking
up the image that came from
let's try picking up this actual image
here that had the had the oranges in it
this is they see that what happens is
because Oh a
I let's try it let's try doing this
let's try doing that and then let's try
running the apples orange Network on
something which is already an apple see
what it does um and then maybe what we
can do here oh oh that's really weird
that's even more Apple than Apple's um
wow that's interesting now I'm really
curious what happens okay we have to do
this let us do a nest list just applying
that same network multiple times to that
image of these red apples so let's go
ahead and apply it five five successive
times this may be a horrible mistake but
let's see what it does
oh wow okay so apparently those are
progressively more Apple II apples um
if we wanted to we could probably see
what happens to this network if we just
look partway through the execution of
that network but let's not do that right
now let's sum let's pick another kind of
thing so another big thing that's new
and 11.3 there's a lot of new functions
for facial um I could talk about some
things and maybe people are interested
I'll talk about some things that are new
in detailed handling of neuron that's a
lot of things particularly to do with
recurrent neural nets and sequence
things to do with sequences in neural
nets some fairly technical things about
net state objects and so on that are
relevant for neural nets that
progressively learn from new input and
so on um maybe actually while we're
talking about um well we're talking
about some just general machine learning
let me show you a function we've had
feature space plots in 2d we now have a
speechless place plot 3d so for example
if I were to take I don't know letters
of the alphabet for example and take
images of all the letters of the
alphabet okay um I could say I could
take those and I could say make a 3d
feature space plot of all those letters
and see which which letters are closest
in this 3d feature space
what we're seeing here is okay in 3d
feature space V&Y always seem to be
pretty close
what are those ones up there as we
rotate around we'll see different things
here R and C are fairly close but we can
see these in 3d feature space and we
could do that actually here's a good
example of something we can do let's get
let's get 250 random colors and let's
try putting those let's put those in 2d
feature space and now that we'll try to
arrange things in some kind of color
triangle but what I'm curious about is
if we do 3d feature space will this
rediscover RGB color umm so that's line
21 let's see so this is this interesting
okay so this is now this is now it's
sort of rediscovering some things over
there in okay there are the Reds there
are the yellows greens etc um so
actually if we were to try let's just
try for example let's see how this did
in terms of from actually laying this
out um chromaticity plot 3d okay let's
see how the still in terms are actually
laying out the things on line 21
this would be the actual plot in 3d
color space
um and it's hard to tell what the
correspondences between these things um
okay well let me um yeah just I'll save
this because we can actually look at it
I could actually why don't I do this
while we're at it let me and go ahead
and save this out to 11 3-1 okay I'm
gonna show you something interesting
that we can now do so I can take this
and it's a slightly big notebook but let
me go ahead and just cloud publish this
notebook and let me call it some cloud
publish it as well actually I just
published the evaluation notebook the
current notebook and let's call it
eleven point three - oh one okay
I'm living dangerously because I'm not
quite sure what this is gonna do but
let's give it a try so what this should
do is to go ahead and publish this quite
big notebook out to the Wolfram cloud
okay there we go
so now I made a cloud object and that
should be a public cloud object that
anybody can pick up actually um let me
see what happens if I go there let me
let me just um so that I'm really doing
it as an anybody I'm going to use an
incognito window and my browser here and
I'm going to go and see what happens I'm
going to go there and there's all kinds
of technology that has to work in order
for this to operate correctly it may not
have yet had time to cache all of the
stuff that is in there um but this
should steadily get all of the stuff
published here hmm okay I think it'll
come um all right well let me keep going
here anyway um so let me just just to
show you a small example of that let me
just let me just take a few a few things
here um and let me just say for those
let me make another notebook here and
let me just go ahead and cloud publish
that notebook so that will now just take
the content there and publish it um and
let me see here
so that's rather
am it's a UUID there that it made but
okay so now now we published this and
here we have it in a cloud and we can
probably oh that's just oh these things
didn't come out as 3d plots it's a shame
anyway so that's just a web page that
anybody can go to and if you want it to
you could open it um in here I can open
it here up now I have to actually sign
in and then I can open it and actually
be editing it if I want to right there
in the cloud so I'm editing my copy of
this I'm right in the cloud to to do
different things so let's say here um
this is just going to load in and I can
be be doing all kinds of computations
here whatever I want to do I can now be
just going ahead and computing in the
cloud and and by the way big software
engineering effort is that yes there's
11.3 now running live in the cloud as
well as on the desktop ok well let's
let's go back here let's see I was on a
path to show you're the UM the
other kinds of things here I was going
to talk about face related functions so
we have a function called find faces so
let's let's go ahead and find a picture
where as a good picture I was using I
was using some pictures from famous some
for famous to physicists at least
there's a thing that was called the
Solvay conference um let's just see
whether we can um pull in some pictures
from the Solvay conference from around
1919 now nineteen more like nineteen
twenty actually um the okay so here's a
here's a random sample picture let's see
what we can get here there's one let's
take that picture um and let's see what
happens if we say find faces on that
picture and see ok so those are
rectangles for the faces and if I look
up some documentation
oops I'm using let me go back to the
page I was using before because I was I
had a notebook where I had everything
nice and magnified let's go back to that
one um ok let's use this magnified one
ok here we go
so now when in doubt of course look at
the documentation so let me go ahead and
do that
um and
[Music]
um so here I want to actually find
images there so let me say find faces ,
image here and what that should do okay
there we go
so that picked up a bunch of bunch of
faces there
picked out from that image now what I
could do also is to take that image and
make a dataset of what it knows about
those faces oh no that's not what I want
what why what's here I probably want um
- just say facial features and then I
want to say dataset let's know what am i
doing I don't know what I'm doing
um let's some
let's see happens if I just do this this
is now going to so the way things like
facial features work is they're using a
an underlying neuron that we can
probably find the neuron that that's
actually using in the neural net
repository okay here we go
and now let's make that into a data set
and we will find various various faces
here and boy I don't know whether that I
don't know whether those ages are
correct they seem like they're roughly
correct at least but that that's the
kind of thing we can easily do here so
for example if we say the
um let's try just for fun I'm curious
I'm gonna go one of these very self
oriented dumb things let's go find my
own scrapbook um and let's pick out
let's pick out a random picture yeah
there's a picture now I'm curious how
old I was in that picture it says 1964
there I wonder if it's actually true
let's see let me try you know the
question is which do I trust my um okay
so let's try facial features and let's
see maybe it'll pick up the face of the
guinea pig instead um that is very
unconvincing
look at that okay well that's definitely
wrong well don't always trust in there
on that um the okay happy to see the
guinea pig but definitely the wrong age
um so it goes let's try one more let's
try something like come and try my old I
see this is way too small to few bits
there
let's try yeah there we go maybe that
will do big enough let's try my 1979
student and faculty ids from Caltech um
let's see whether it can now those must
have been spaced by about a year so
let's see um see what it does on those
two so they can find the faces well
that's not bad
it's not right but it's some oh wow it
thought that was a face of age 39 that's
kind of crazy but um well that's off by
a couple of years there it thought I was
older than then it thinks I was older
than I actually was um so it goes um
okay let's go back here um the um it's
someone was asking is fine faces a
totally new function eleven three orders
exist previously there was a fine faces
but it did not work using modern Iran
that techniques and it certainly wasn't
as powerful as the one we have here um
okay well that's some that's that's one
kind of thing let's go how about we go
to a completely different actually I'll
tell you what let's show geo smooth
histogram I'm just going to show some
visualization features so let's let's go
pick up some data some geo related data
how about we go and look for how about
we look go to our data repository and
let's look for geography let's do it as
a nice ok how about this let's go solid
waste landfill facilities that's a good
obscure thing alright let's let's pull
in the okay so let's pull this in so
this will now be pulling this in from
our from our data repository we're
loading in a bunch of data that
hopefully we'll be able to go go look at
ok here we go so this is random data
let's take a look here um whether we
have ok it's got phone numbers come on
it's got to have coordinates this must
have coordinates maybe it doesn't well
we'll find out in a minute ok well there
at least it's got cities that's a good
start
alright so let's pick out these our
landfills apparently and let's go ahead
and say line 36 let's say we want to
pick out for all of those I want the
city entity um and that will pick out
all the cities there um let's pick a
6,000 of those but let's just pick um
let's just start off by saying um
random sample of let's say 300 of those
now let's say 500 um
and let's see what happens if we just
say we might just be able to say geo
smooth histogram of this um right was it
called geo I think that's right
so
weird that it wasn't otto completing
their very strange actually all right
let's see what happens if I just do this
so now I'm I'm just feeding it those
five hundred cities it's gonna have to
figure out where all those cities are
and then what it's going to try to do is
to show us kind of a density map of of
these cities
um the okay um while it's doing that
actually I don't know how long it's
going to take I think it may be taking
awhile to find um find the locations of
all those cities um but let's um let's
go ahead and okay we'll have it go think
about that for a moment meanwhile let me
just show you let's go look at
see here let's look in the neuron that
repository just for fun let's let's go
find the actual neural net that deals
with with face related things so ho
predict a person's age from image of
their face so that's probably the the
network but it's using four
for that computation um so we can oh is
this kind of interesting you can say we
can just take that Network because of
interest kind of to neuron that
aficionados you can take that network
that exists and more from language and
you can just export it raw - something
like MX net um and well there's a
there's a picture of the actual graph of
that Network and why is this taking so
unbelievably long well let's do this
that's let's cool that off um that's not
what I wanted
I wanted to just abort that and let me
just take from ah I'm 38 let me just see
what happens if I just say geo position
of take and that that's 38 let's just
take 40 of those from there hope didn't
like that so let's see if I say um this
okay this is what's taking it a while oh
there we go okay
so a few of those I see a few of those
it wasn't even able to find locations
but let's let's take let's just delete
missing um
that's the problem the problem is that
it doesn't know okay so what I should
have done here is to take the things in
line 38 and just say delete missing on
that and now I will have something dense
and now I can say hopefully geo position
of those and doesn't like it for some
reason let's see um geo position oh I
know would have to do this um I'm 42
what was I doing here Oh silly me okay
um so hopefully this will look up all
these okay there we go finally we got
the geo positions okay so now let's say
geo smooth histogram of that and what it
will do is to take that distribution of
point okay there we go
so that shows the density of it's not
very exciting but it's the it's the
density of waste disposal um it must be
all those wiser it's the population
density in New England or it's all those
very eco proper New Englanders I'm not
sure um we could we could take this and
we can kind of divide by the the
population density of the US or all
kinds of one fun things like that if we
wanted to but there's some there's a
start for that all right let's let's go
tackle a completely different area here
let me so I was showing a few examples
of things like come okay somebody's
asking if we can increase the size here
where did I go a larger screen and let
me go up to 150 percent if we go much
larger than that it's going to be hard
to to get much in here
okay I'm gonna show you something
completely different let's go
well actually I'm curious to try
something here um no I'm gonna show you
something completely different let's
let's go really mathy I'm gonna show you
something about mathematical proofs and
particular what I want to show you if I
can pick this up here is here we go
let's try this um so what this is doing
is it's saying here's oh we need to have
hey let's take a look here this is an
axiom system for group theory okay so
it's saying for all a B and C G we
haven't said what years of a and G B C
equals so this is an associative law
this here is I guess this is the
identity law this is for all a this says
that G G must be the group
multiplication operation a multiplied by
a inverse of a is the identity element
okay so now we're going to try and make
a proof based on we're gonna may try
make a proof of this statement G of well
this whole long statement here we're
gonna try and prove that given the
axioms of group theory okay um
and let's sum so what that's doing that
was really fast well um normally
immortan language we're trying to just
figure out results we're trying to say
you know what is 2+2 it's 4 we're not
trying to say give us a proof that 2+2
is 4 you know I'm more from alpha we
have the show steps mechanism that is
widely used by students you know in math
and chemistry and other places where
it's saying okay this was the result for
the integral now show me the steps this
is kind of a much more heavy duty
version of that so let's take a look at
some at this we can say something like
proof I think it's called
proof network is that right
so let's try doing something like proof
proof graph for example so this is
showing so this particular thing but
let's actually let's start off with
proof data set so question is why is
this result true okay and the answer is
here's the proof it's twenty nine steps
long and it says we start off from this
axiom x1 is G of X 1 e etc etcetera
etcetera we're starting with this axiom
and then we're going to go through
figuring out a bunch of intermediate
lemmas and eventually we're going to get
the results ok um and for example we can
just show sort of what's the network of
what depends on what in that proof so we
can go ahead and say proof graph so
that's showing us how the different
lemmas improving this come from each
other and if we wanted to we could also
say give me a proof function which is
just a function which we can evaluate
take this whole proof function and
really it just defines a bunch of
substitutions that are purely structural
substitutions that we take that function
and apply it to nothing it'll rather
unexcited
we turn true and what that means is that
you can have you can you can validate
that this is a correct theorem
somebody's asking about wishes wolf now
for the open source well you know you
can get all this stuff you just go to
the web you can just use all the stuff
for free um just go to go to the web you
can um just go wolf and calm you can
start um let's see we could go here for
example and you just go there and go to
creating your notebook and you don't
have to login or a thing you can just
start doing all the stuff in fact I'm
gonna try let me live really dangerously
here and I'm actually going to try doing
the thing I just did here which is a
very new new thing but let's see whether
I can actually do that right here free
on on the web
that's some go there let's see whether
this works um let's take this and let's
try it oh wow that was cool okay let's
see if I can go and get the proof graph
there so this is this is just running in
a you know you can just go to this web
browser go to a web browser and you can
just be be running this stuff
immediately um you don't actually even
have to log in um so hopefully you find
that useful um the other thing that's
interesting of course about all this
stuff is um you can go let's see yeah so
asking questions about do we have stuff
to do with Bayesian statistics we have
all kinds of stuff to do with Bayesian
all kinds of things I don't know if I
say something like um that's just this
is this is not new in in version 3 but
like at eleven point three but I'll show
you something could do I could say let's
just look at some statistical kinds of
things so let's say we have X is
distributed according to let's say a log
normal distribution
um I'm very confused by something here
about this what I'm running here because
I'm not seeing the usual what on earth
is going on I am NOT this is making it
much harder for me I'm not seeing the
usual Auto completions that I would see
and that's some it's very peculiar to me
um
you
and okay so anyway let's um let's see
how many parameters does the log normal
distribution have um you know this is
really odd I'm going to um okay let's
see - coma - for example um okay so
let's say X is distributed according to
that I could for example say give me a
let's say let's just take that log
normal distribution and say give me a
hundred random variates distributed
according to that log normal
distribution
let's say I can do let's say I take a
make a histogram with a thousand random
variates distributed according to that
normal distribution okay there I get the
results now I can just say give me find
the expectation value of x cubed let's
say with X distributed according to that
log normal distribution that wasn't too
exciting the answer was either the 24th
let's see if I make this much more
difficult - maybe it won't even be
possible say it's X cubed over 1 plus X
and see whether I can evaluate that
distributed um the that way so
let's see
someone is asking about well we can
assure you all kinds of stuff I'm not
sure exactly what you want to do with
Bayesian statistics but there's lots of
different things there but someone is
asking about functional reactive
programming so so we have this whole
mechanism for um whole dynamic mechanism
that we've had for 20 years actually it
allows one to UM do so for example let
me see what I can can make something
there that is useful let's sum okay
let's see if I let's get an image here
see if I do current image um and
you
then I know I have to let's see um I
need to tell it which um I need to let's
do this let's say image capture
and hopefully it will allow me to
control which device let's try that one
there
all right let's see oh that's a
thrilling image of my desk here let's
put a nice let's put something something
good in the middle there ok so now we
should be able to do a current image
here and it should be able to get what
is going on there
let's see you know I need to get this so
that it is autocomplete incorrectly and
I don't know what's happened to me here
that's causing that not to not to occur
so I'm going to actually quit this
notebook and see what happens
I may have been running a new version
that is even newer than 11.3 that came
out today but so let me let me make sure
I'm actually running the correct version
um and that's also a bit strange that
it's not connecting to the cloud
immediately what did this just do that
just reopened that notebook that's very
odd okay let's let's go ahead and start
a new notebook and let me go to 150%
again and let me see whether this
strange problem has gone away oh yeah
there we go okay we're all good umm okay
let's see where were we we were trying
to do current image let's see where the
current image will pick up something
okay so I think we need to do um I need
to tell it which imaging device to use
and I wonder who that documentation
writer was um okay imaging device stole
our imaging device okay let's cut our
imaging device um that's trial McDowell
imaging devices that will tell me my
various imaging devices and I want that
creature there so that's the fourth
imaging device so I want to say Dalek
imaging device equals that thing the
third one of those okay now let's try
current image there we go okay that's my
desk um with a nice sum a nice patch
there okay so let's so we talked about
dynamic um so if I say dynamic
of that I can go ahead and I can do a
computation on that for example let's
just do dynamic image there I can just
put my hand in there and wiggle it
around but let's say I do a more
non-trivial computation I could for
example Oh a typical thing I might do
let's try living really dangerously okay
just for fun let me do this let me take
um well I can just do a trivial thing
like I can just do edge detection okay
that's but that's no fun that's that's
um I can just take take the current
image here and um age detect from it and
I'll get that and I could say here and
make this work dynamically I can just
say dynamically edge detect that um and
now I can get something where I can move
it around like this but let me do
something more ambitious let me say
instead of doing that let me take that
thing and let me go ahead and say
actually here let's do this let's just
let's just do this let's just say
chromaticity plot to 3d okay so what
that's now going to do is it's going to
show me in real time
what so I can probably move it around if
I want to but but um it's going to show
me in real time there I'm putting the
red that's actually I should probably
let me put another one in here so you
can see what it's doing so let's do
another dynamic here um and go ahead and
say dynamic of of current image here um
it's really burning a lot of CPU effort
to UM to keep updating that but now
we'll be able to see both of them and
now we'll be able to see if I put that
red much closer um it will it will get
some it will they'll be much many more
red pixels there okay so that's that's
kind of an example of how you can do
dynamic things in our language um and
works really very generally I mean you
can do that
so okay let's see someone's asking about
deep learning and training yeah you can
absolutely do training I mean let's do
we can do a simple training and then
let's do a less trivial training I mean
if I just say let's go to our on that
repository and we can say net model of
you know some simple Network like
Lynette for example and then we could
get the untrained initialization Network
for Lynette um untrained okay I probably
want uh no oh there's an update
available great it's actually I'm just
going to that's just that's it's kind of
interesting to see what it looks like
actually if I go ahead and update all
the neural nets from so there's a neural
net that I must have downloaded
previously okay so these are no nuts
that I downloaded previously and other
things that I downloaded previously that
I that I just got updates for um okay so
let's go ahead and get that Network here
let me cop copy it down here and let me
just to organize myself let me put in
this notebook network training that's
gonna be the section that we're going to
be working on here okay so here's a
network right so we can look at this
network and it's an uninitialized
network so if I take this network I
could say net initialize on this network
and that'll give me a randomly
initialized network so if I now take I
might take the amnesty data set so I
could say resource data of M nest so
that's in I did a repository and I could
say give me a random sample of um well
let's just get the whole in this data
set first okay so now it's going to
download the MS data set um and it'll
format take a little while probably to
format it's maybe I don't know how big
it is fifty thousand things okay there's
a bunch of handwritten digits okay so
let's feed this totally randomly
initialized neuron that's up here on
line 14 let's feed it a zero and we can
guarantee pretty much it's going to give
some stupid answer like five right
because an untrained network but now if
we wanted to we could take that on that
randomly initialized
work on line 14 and we could say net
train that Network uh online let's see
we can just take this network here um
should be able to take that network and
say train that on a random sample of
let's see of the emne Stata set um I'm
just making a line where you can see
everything going on here let's say a
random sample of 2,000 elements from the
MS data set
oops let me do this instead so let me
just say let me just take the things
thing on line 14 okay here we go so this
is now oh okay all right so now this is
actual training going on so what it's
gonna do here oh gosh it's gonna train
too quickly for me to be able to talk
about it um so what you see here the
error rate is going down the loss is
going down so this is now training on
2,000 samples 2,000 randomly selected
samples from this data set it's training
a network and what's going to come out
now is after this is done is a trained
network and let's see what happens okay
so there's a training network and now
let's feed in a zero to our train
network and with luck it should actually
generate a zero and it does um now if we
wanted to we could take a network oh
it's kind of interesting is to take
networks from the neural net repository
for example let's take one of these some
let's take one of these glove
networks this is a network that gives um
word vectors so if I take that and I say
happy it's probably going to give me
it's going to so it's going to download
that network oops it's a fairly big
network 250 megabyte network um this is
a network that is trying to give
essentially meaning vectors for words
and let's take a look at what happens
here so we can go ahead and um come on
just have to download it and
then that network will then be local on
my machine by the way if I was doing
this in the cloud it wouldn't have to
download it because the network is
already right there in the cloud um but
then I wouldn't be using my own machine
CPU I will be using the machine the the
cloud CPU ok so that was the word vector
for the word happy so let's do this
let's pick
let's pick 50 random words in English I
could do it in a different language as
well but that's ok there are 50 random
words in English and let's go ahead and
make a 3d feature space plot 3 3d
feature space plots are a new feature in
version 11 point 3 so let's go ahead in
line 20 and let's say the feature
extractor is
to extract is this net model here so
we're going to use that net model to
determine what the features are that
we're going to be using to determine
where these words should go in feature
space okay so what should be happening
here there we go okay so now what we've
got is those words um why is it spinning
um
pick up computer so those those words
let's make this a bit bigger
and we can see what I I can't I have no
this is not this is not our model this
is that this is a weight vector trained
on on tweets which we didn't we didn't
train this so why Beach and luggage okay
they're fairly close together yeah
there's some pretty weird weird
correspondences here um so so anyway the
actually what we could do just for fun
we could see what our built in feature
space um
plot does for that um for that case why
is this taking so long to copy upon um
let's just try
scene
there we go um
okay so this was our built-in feature
space plot that looks a lot more
convincing a lot more convincing
friendliness and gratefulness or close
together and godless is unfortunately
near gratefulness oh well um
[Music]
mathematician is near mistreatment okay
I can't speak to that one either um okay
so let's see I'm trying to so somebody's
asking about deep learning training I
showed you an example of that
we can do a much more serious training
and you can do it as a matter of fact
one of the things that's new in version
11 point 3 is [ __ ] link so MongoDB is a
database system that's good for managing
it's actually what we use internally to
manage large-scale large-scale training
in the cloud we actually and this is now
a bunch of functions to support using
dealing with terabyte sized data sets
using MongoDB and that's that's what we
use with our machine learning training
system which is ultimately based on MX
net we use that to Train um in in the
cloud
we've been big contributors to MX net I
think you asked about Amazon Amazon I
think it's also a big contributor to our
max net um don't know if they're bigger
than us so we're bigger than them in
terms of contributing to that open
source library um okay let's see um
is there a new way is there a
standardized way to analyze and report
data for example if you're classifying
data well yeah you can do things like
for example let's say I pick what should
we do here let's do this let's say um I
well in fact this feature space plot is
a pretty good example of but we could do
some clustering so for example if I took
I think I had those random paintings so
let's say whatever it was I had um
Monet artworks let's try getting a list
of those um okay so I was using natural
language understanding okay so I've got
a bunch of artworks here let's go pick
um entity value that comma let's just
take the first um let's take the
20 of those and let's try and get images
of those that see how many of these
pictures we have okay so we have all of
all but one of those okay so one thing
we can do if we're trying to do some
analysis on this is something like
delete missing
to get rid of that missing one the first
thing we could do is just do a feature
space plot and then that will show us
sort of how those pictures are
distributed in a feature space so those
various haystacks seemed like they show
up together um I guess this whatever
that picture is very watercolor II type
picture shows up together we could also
do something like um how about
clustering tree
so we could say clustering tree of the
images on line 25 and so now that will
be a different kind of analysis that
will show us how those images cluster um
how we can how we can make sort of a
phylogenetic tree so if if these were
images that kind of had evolved one from
another we might learn about that from
this clustering tree um we can do all
kinds of other computations on these
images and get results from that let's
see when will n-body simulation be
employed as a matter of fact if you
watch some of our live streamed design
reviews you might know that we're
actually working on a very general and
body simulation system it wasn't ready
for 11.3 it will be ready for the next
version um let's see somebody here is
Jose Ignacio
Aska Dara Jimmy is saying I published
wolf now for dotnet an open source
library that lets you work with off now
for API is from dotnet very nice cool
it's some in general you know you can I
mean making an API in Wolfram language
is very easy you can let me just show
you how you'd make an API let's make an
API that for example
let's make a picture of an animal let's
make an API that makes a picture of an
animal and the color negated version of
the animal okay so to do that let's make
a let's first of all make a form that
says you type in an animal and see its
of type animal I think that's a type
let's just check that that's a type um
interpreter animal let's see if I type
in ox for example yeah good it knows
that um it interprets that natural
language there okay so here we go so now
let's say we're going to go let's say
with an image that's equal to hash
animal
I'll get an image from that and now
we'll say that image let's get just
let's say just a list the image and the
color negation of that image um and
let's maybe I don't know we can do
something more fun with it but let's
just do that and let's say we're gonna
return it as a PNG and now let's just
say cloud deploy that so just make that
something available in the cloud and
let's actually make it so anybody if you
write down the URL you can just go there
we can make it a public deployment so
let's go ahead and do that oops I forgot
the very important thing here um
I forgot to tell it that this was going
to be a function okay so now let's go
there now this is going to go what did i
do horribly wrong oh I did that that was
a horribly bad idea
let's deploy the right thing now um okay
so now this will deploy as a form on the
web and it says you know fill in an
animal so for example I could fill in
ostrich for example here and let me go
ahead and and run it okay that's cool so
there I've got a picture of an ostrich
now why did I get this um Oh what are
you wrong here I said with that
two-color negate it what did I do wrong
with my ostrich um I should have had a
an image and the colour negation let me
see what happened let's take that image
and
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh that's funny okay
what I did there was I made an animated
PNG I just gave the PNG a list of images
there and that will have made an
animated PNG so actually if I really
wanted to live dangerously I would I
would let's do this
let us do this we could we could make a
successively blurred ostrich if we
wanted to but let me let me do something
which isn't quite as silly so let's say
graphics row of those and let me
redeploy this and now let me try an
ostrich again um and there we go now we
have the ostrich and the colour negated
ostrich um it will be fun though let's
make an animated ostrich just for fun um
well let's make an ostrich I'll tell you
what let's go ahead and make something
see if I can make this work let's go
ahead and make something where we
actually have the image there and we say
make something where we can manipulate
the image and we successively blur the
image by okay here we go this is really
kind of high-tech but let's um see what
happens here so let's say blur that up
to 20 pixels and now I want to close
that and I want to do that and let's try
what did I do wrong here I said I've
been doing crazy surgery to this okay
that seems right and now I want to
and the there we go so there's the form
function and then I deploy it okay so
now what I should get here is when I
deploy this let's try a different animal
let's try a giraffe what I should get
here see what this works as I should get
an interactive interface there we go um
which has a giraffe in it and I can go
ahead and isn't this cool I can go ahead
so I just deployed I just said make an
interactive interface here and as I move
the end of it so I just on-the-fly
created an interactive interface that um
will make me able to blur the picture of
the giraffe now let's take this one back
here because I was talking about api's
and let's turn this thing into a an API
function so now this will become a Web
API if I don't give it a parameter it
will just fail but if I say question
mark animal equals antelope for example
then it will run that computation and
generate a picture of an antelope okay
and if I wanted to just for this
particular API I could say make me the
embed code for this in let's say we have
let's see how do we say dotnet well
let's do um let's just say Java here um
that so that's now embed code Java embed
code that will call that API in the
cloud and actually one of the things
that's interesting now is that if you're
making a an API that you want to charge
for for example you can start doing that
because you can set up an API where for
example there's a permissions key that
you need to use or you can say generate
secured authentication key that's a very
long function but this generates an
OAuth key that you can then give to
users to be able to call so this earth
key would be put in the embed code
food that you would then put in a
program to call that API so this this
allows you to do the whole Roth
transaction
okay so let's see somebody was asking
here is there an efficient way to
implement Monte Carlo Markov chain Monte
Carlo sure let's see um
Markov chain Monte Carlo uh yeah we
actually have a whole lot of things this
is not new in inversion 11.3 but I can
um let's just look at what um we have a
whole lot of stuff for doing that yeah
look here's that here's a random process
here's a guide to random processes so
for example we could say discrete Markov
process and so for example let's take an
example here so this actually represents
a discrete markov process with okay so
that means that's an initial state 1 0 0
and those are the transition vectors
that's the transition matrix and now
what I could do okay I can compute let's
try to compute so let's say that's the
process now I could say let me try doing
this again I'm living a little
dangerously here let's say random let's
see how do I do this what I want to do
is I want to work out the I want to give
you a Monte Carlo simulation of that
random process so I can say I could ask
for the stationary distribution of that
process and that will give me that will
just compute something which i think is
probably analytically computable there
it says the stationary distribution of
that Markov chain is the discrete
uniform distribution up 1 3 but I can
also do a I could also I think do a
[Music]
just yeah here we go simulator random
process here we go so what I want to do
then is I'll say a random function using
the discrete Markov process line 37 I
think I know what I'm doing here
well let's see what this works zero to
20 for example okay cool alright so now
I wonder what happens if I just say date
list lots of that yes okay so that is
showing me a Monte Carlo simulation that
has been done of a single path in this
discrete Markov process done by by
running that thing now if I know what
I'm doing here which I am Not sure I do
there we go generates an ensemble of n
pseudo-random functions ok so let's go
ahead here and say let's say 20
pseudo-random functions
ok now let's plot this and now what
we'll get is 20 samples of that Markov
process ok and if we wanted to I could
now say I could now do computations on
this I mean I can make a more exciting
Markov process but that perhaps gives an
idea how to implement so this is you're
asking other ways to implement Markov
chain Monte Kahlo's I think that's the
answer and I can get the distribution
out from that and everything does does
Wolfram language include database of
word meanings yes it does if I say let's
do this let's say it's always fun to say
you know you can estimate how many words
you know in English by just picking
let's say you have let's say I have 10
random words and let's see if I know the
meanings of all of those mmm I think I
do
open-work not completely sure I know
what that is
um any way I could say give me word
definitions of those I have to say what
definition of each of those things in
line 43 and now it'll have to load in
some data but it should be able to give
me those definitions um ok there we go
so uh and yes we can obviously get
synonyms and things like that from this
we have a whole network of of word
functions that do does things like this
and actually if we um let's just take
something like this and just for fun if
we're if we're interested in words we
can do something a lot of sophisticated
things actually coming through machine
learning but um
one one thing here okay actually I need
to show you a couple of important things
oops I need to say oh that's not what I
wanted
silly me um this is this is going to do
make a parse tree from that using
actually neural network methods it's
going to make a parse tree and that does
not look right what is that
grammatical unit missing how odd um
[Music]
anyway um okay I want to show you
something and I'm going to come back to
this I want to show you something that's
new in version version 11.3 which is um
so let me just pull in the
[Music]
pedia article for ostriches about
ostriches just because I want some text
data okay so let's say this is let's
just call this ostrich um
and now for example I could take ostrich
there and I could go ahead and say um I
could say make me a word cloud of the
words in the article about ostriches and
we'll probably give me a word cloud here
or I can say let us this is the new
thing I can say find textual answer and
now this is using state-of-the-art
question-answering technology so let's
see how fast does an ostrich run and
let's see what it does so now it's going
to it's gonna have to load in a neural
net to go do this it's big neuron that
I'm actually we can go see in the neural
net repository what the neuron that
actually is um it's taking its time to
figure this out it's a big long article
about ostriches so it's some okay that's
fascinating okay it's a slightly silly
answer I would say but not obviously
totally stupid let's see the top five
answers it got for how fast does not
stretch run um it's saying okay well
that's 270 kilometers per hour okay
there's some slightly goofy things there
I wonder whether we know actually um I
don't know whether we would know it um I
think wolf not oh there we go
that's cool so wolf Malthus says it's 45
miles an hour let's see how that
compares to unit convert to what it said
in the Wikipedia article I'm guessing as
a human I can kind of guess that this is
the most likely I could for example
select these four ones that are
quantities that correspond to speeds but
I could also just say unit converts
actually I just say unit convert of that
it tells me in meters per second so I
can say unit convert that to kilometers
per hour um and then it says wonderful
okay that's kind of interesting so the
Wolfram Alpha from our knowledge base
it's saying about 42 miles an hour here
it's say I mean 70 72 kilometers per
hour here at 770 kilometers per hour but
what's interesting is the extreme non
triviality of of being able to do this
question answering which of course like
many of these things isn't perfectly
reliable so if I say what does an
ostrich eat I have no idea what kind of
thing it's going to come up with let's
let's do five of those and let's see
what it comes up with um so okay insects
such as locusts okay so the only one
here that actually is a human looks
plausible and that's kind of life doing
natural language processing but this is
a lovely state-of-the-art thing and
actually we could go ahead and we could
say wonder if we have it um see whether
I'm not sure if this is loaded up to the
new on that repository yet but coming
soon will be the actual Network for fine
textual answer okay let me go back here
somebody's asking a pipeline
non-subscription a lot for how long will
I ever access to 3,000 API calls per
month I sadly I am just the CEO and I
don't know the answer to that um the
you can deploy api's and you get
depending on which plan you have you get
some number of free api calls per month
I believe these I mean it's it's these
API calls or not unless you're grinding
us CPU for an awfully long time
these are not
[Music]
expensive API calls let's see so in
summary we can gives pre-trained neuron
that some repository but the option of
training our own DNN models in the cloud
rather than locally is not ready no no
you can absolutely train these things in
the cloud you can I mean you can use our
cloud to do training it's I'm not sure
that's the best the most economical
thing to do the option of using for
example the Amazon Cloud for really
large-scale training is well you can do
that but it's a little bit of a
do-it-yourself kit right now we have all
the technology to do that and we will be
releasing it fairly soon um in terms of
building your own models no no you can
absolutely build your own model however
you want we're we're really proud of the
symbolic let's take an example well
let's just do something like
[Music]
let's take an LS TM for example and we
can we can build up to try and see
whether there's an application here
these are kind of complicated
unfortunate as soon as you get too
sophisticated okay well there's an
example okay there's an example so
that's how you actually build a neural
nets from scratch in our system okay so
there was a net encoder here this is a
little bit complicated because we've got
um we've got to have a net encoder to
get the input but let's just take a look
at what happens here so there what
you're seeing is this is generating a
neuron that it's an uninitialized neuron
that's here and you are so I could I
could initialize it or what you're
seeing here is these an LS TM layer
these linear layers and so on what's
extremely non-trivial is that you can
fit these arbitrary length sequences all
together in this and for example if I
say net initialize it will initialize
that network randomly in this case and I
don't know what this actually takes is
input let's see characters digit
character in a plus sign okay so if I
feed into this and this is probably
going to do something totally ridiculous
but but let's say I feed in something
like this to this uninitialized neural
net so it's gonna produce garbage um
okay so that kind of amusing way it let
me just try because it's it's one of
those things where you just have to have
memorable moments for what neuron that's
do it's not easy to teach a neural net
arithmetic and now we're asking this
particular untrained neural nets the
newborn baby and you're all nuts what is
two plus two and the answer it says is
minus zero point zero two now hopefully
if we trained it it would know better
but this is roughly how you start
building up neural nets from scratch and
you can then go ahead and do training on
this um and so on and the point is you
can take a neural net from the
repository and you can take it apart and
do that or you can build your own your
on that from scratch or you can glue
together pieces from the repository and
so on okay somebody's asking about
blockchain
uhh
let's see somebody is asking about
bioinformatics I don't know I mean let's
let's just do just for fun let's do a
little bit of bioinformatics let's say
let's just do okay let's start off with
something really basic let's say I pick
a random base pair sequence here um
let's see what happens ah no hits on the
human genome that by default okay so
there are some hits on the human genome
to that base pair sequence let me let me
try I'm gonna try let me do something
totally outrageous let me do
let's do genome data and let's do
see what I'm doing here I might need to
look up how this works um
mitochondrion
let's see I want to do the strand let's
do the positive strand oh the
mitochondrion and let's try and do the
whole mitochondrion and let's go ahead
see whether you get the human
mitochondria in here and while it's
looking for the human mitochondrion I am
going to go somewhere else to a little
secret stash of data that I have here
and let me see if I can do this um where
would it be um hold on one second
[Music]
sorry just a moment here I'm hoping I'm
going to find from lucky I'm going to
find a um you see what I have here yes I
might have what I need okay what I'm
gonna do here if this works when a
dragged over from here I'm going to drag
there we go
that should be my mitochondrion so it's
called @ SW mitochondrion um I've had
this sequence turn awfully large number
of times now through having had my whole
genome sequence back in 2010 and various
other sequencing adventures um
okay actually you know what I want to do
I want to say um it's just the I just
want to get the actual string there so
there's my mitochondrion and there's the
reference mitochondrion online 65 and so
the obvious thing for me to do is to say
sequence alignment of the reference
mitochondrion which was on line 65 and
SW use mitochondrion which was there and
now it'll go and do alignment for these
two two things okay ah you know what I
did I got the wrong strand I um
my mitochondrion let's take a look how
it start starts GA T and this reference
one no it's also starting GA t alright
so maybe this what did I do wrong here
um GA t what did I do wrong am
I asking it to do oh no no I didn't do
anything wrong this is exactly right
okay this is exactly right this is
saying most of my mitochondrion is
exactly the same as the reference
mitochondrion but here is the first snip
my first variant snip and then there are
a few other variants snips let's find
out so we can figure out for example
let's see let's find out how many
variants snips I have so let's just say
count in that the number of blank blanks
like that so therefore I have 47 I am a
pretty average human with 47 the
variations from the reference
mitochondrial DNA sequence um we have
actually a lot of capabilities in these
areas we actually have one big thing
that's coming is the ability to deal
with arbitrary molecules um ok so let's
see I'm
[Music]
someone's asking about blockchain okay
let's talk about blockchain nice topical
area all right so we have several ways
of interacting with a blockchain let's
first of all let's some let's go ahead
and set the blockchain base to be
Bitcoin this will be the main Bitcoin
blockchain and so I can say blockchain
data of well for example I could just
say blockchain data for that main
blockchain and that will tell me that
there are 500,000 blocks and the Bitcoin
blockchain but more interestingly I can
say black lime block data and I could
for example say what's the most recent
block that got added to the Bitcoin
blockchain so there it is it just got
added just got mind Oh
ten minutes ago well yeah well that's
the Bitcoin blockchain okay so we can
see there there are a bunch of
transactions we could go pick out a
transaction here and now we can go and
say well lots of transactions in that
block well that's a lot um so okay so we
can say blockchain transaction data and
we can pick out that block and there we
can see well okay so let's go ahead and
just see um what was transferred there
so that's that number of Bitcoin so
let's see we can say that and we say
currency converts that to US dollars
well okay so somebody just transferred
eighty two dollars and their fee there
see how much it's costing to do
something like that these days their fee
and Satoshi's presumably is
crazy it's costing 12 dollars on the
Bitcoin blockchain right now as of ten
minutes ago - to transfer 82 dollars
that's pretty weird
um so we can go ahead we can do the
ethereum blockchain as well we can look
at transactions there um the
[Music]
um but let's some someone was asking
about our blockchain so we actually have
a Wolfram blockchain which is a uses the
Bitcoin core right now and it's a
blockchain
which is allows you to make essentially
a ledger in our cloud or in a private
cloud so actually with our blockchain I
mean there aren't very many blocks on
our blockchain and if I say blockchain
block data and I look at the most recent
block on our blockchain um it'll be
hopefully wake up there we go okay so it
was mined like a more than an hour ago
because there isn't yet much activity on
this we've only got 2,800 blocks on
there but we can do nice things there so
for example let's let's put um let's
let's pick five random words
and let's just say oh no let's just take
a graphic
um and let's say it's a graphics of
circle no yeah we could we can just take
that graphic and we can say blockchain
put of that graphic and that will put
that graphic onto our blockchain okay
and so that means that we can we can be
sure because our blockchain is being
sequentially added to and so on and
we're also going to be publishing hashes
of our blockchain in various places you
can then be be sure that this really was
put there and if I say blockchain get
from that address it will go ahead and
retrieve that original circle again okay
so the idea of our blockchain is to
provide a convenient ledgering system
for people who have who knows what lab
notebooks they want to confirm you know
they might have some some assets that
they're trying to make a registry for
we're just providing a convenient way to
do that um I mean I have to say that um
the UM it's some the whole world of
smart contracts on the blockchain and so
on we are in this very very interesting
position because Wolfram language is a
language which can make statements about
the real world and it can also connect
to IOT devices and so on in a good way
and this allows us to basically support
Sirius smart contracts that can be
operated from a blockchain or can be
operated not from a blockchain lots of
very interesting things coming in that
area this reminds me of a very important
new area in 11.3 which I really want to
show you that um this is a big big new
area for us this has to do with being
able to get models of devices in the
real world right in the Wolfram language
so we had this product
called system modeler for a number of
years which is a very industrial grade
system for designing and simulating
large-scale objects so let's take an
example let's see this is a little
interface here so let's try heavy
equipment okay let's see what happens if
I try an excavator this may be very
elaborate um
should be an excavator arm that let's
try copying the model this maybe I maybe
this may be a big mistake
where are 6630 equations okay that is a
serious number of equations
um you know what I'm going to before I
before I do the excavator I'm going to
do something a bit simpler um let's try
just educational examples oh uh let's
try one in aerospace engineering um okay
so this is some kind of satellite thingy
um it's called me that model and now
what on earth actually is this we might
ask
let's wait let's wait for it to wake up
again this might be a fairly complicated
model let's try it okay so here's our
here's our model and this is a model
with a bunch of components and
ultimately this model is represented as
a whole lot of equations but we could
say here something like um system model
simulate actually no let me start off
with just system model plot so what
sister model plot is going to do it's
going to take the kind of most obvious
variables here um and it's going to do a
simulation of this model over a certain
period of time and then it's going to
plot the results okay so it's it's
actually doing some very crunchy things
it's doing all sorts of low-level
compilation okay so now it's it would
did a computation okay there we go
so this is now computed from that from
that model it's now computed it's now
essentially solved the equations of that
model to compute these results you know
what I'm gonna I'm gonna start off with
a simpler model because I think it's
gonna be more obvious what's going on so
let's let's go back here and let's say
introductory examples um and let's try
systems
let's try an inverted pendulum here okay
so this is going to be a quite simple
system where we have a okay so this is
our inverted pendulum and then we say
system model plot and then I'm going to
show you so this is now compiling the
model and we can go ahead and there is
the result for our inverted pendulum
there's the angle of the pendulum as a
function of time etc etc now what we can
do here is we could actually go and
change the parameters of this so if I go
in and take that model and I say um and
I just ask what properties does that
model have
it'll probably have all kinds of
properties so for example let's say I
take parameter values let's say I ask it
um
what parameter values does it have um
then I can get those and then I should
be able to okay so this is going to give
me values of the parameters
hopefully wakes up what's it doing um
maybe this is not so trivial what am I
asking it to do maybe it has a lot of
parameters not sure well let's try
I'll tell you what something which I
think must be a lot easier for it let's
just ask it input variables oops
you
so I don't know why this is taking so
long
- just get this to show me
is this so complicated
see it's a bad sign
um the point here anyway is this is some
oh oh there we go oops Oh
that's why I took a while there are tons
of them what a mess my gosh um
try taking a bababa I gotta have a
simpler let's let's do this I'm what I
wanted to show you is how you can
parametrically scan across different
features of parameter space for this
model but let me let me go back here
where we had that a nice little um thing
here and let me just go and we go back
to the examples and let me go and show
you just individual components okay so
let's just say let's try something
really simple
okay let's this is a some kind of
circuit um before we get any more
complicated here this is a circuit with
some it looks like it has some inverters
and things in it okay let's look at that
circuit okay what does it have in it
I'm not sure I can read a circuit
diagram anymore but I think those are
inverters um and okay so let's take this
and let's say we say system model plot
um the
it's simpler now it'll hopefully
generate okay that was really boring so
that's what I get for for having finally
a simple model here so let's let's just
say here see what were they called um I
think we want to call it yeah um let's
just say for this model let's ask what
are the equation what are the um let's
see
parameter values for this model okay
that's a bit simpler right so those are
parameters like the gain of the system
and so on okay so what I could do if I
wanted to is I could say system model
plot um and I could say
there oops therefore I'm going to take
that system model and I'm going to say
system model plot that and then I'm
going to give a parameter value here and
I'm going to say let's say gain that
that gain and now I bet nothing
interesting is going to wind up
happening but anyway let's try it let's
say that gain goes from as n
and I think this is the right way to do
it and let me just make a table of those
things with n goes up to 4 for example
see if this works
Oh silly me ok let's see how this works
when in doubt read the documentation um
so what I need to do is
lots
trivedi bounds when
huh when the parameter value P
okay so this so what I want to do here
just plotting a particular let's just do
that that that's something that's kind
of interesting to see so if I just take
a look at the variables from this and I
will be able to see what um what I can
plot from this
you
system variables is what I want okay so
there for example I could type something
like this gain 3 dot whatever and then I
could say actually what I'll do let's
let's go ahead and plot um a whole bunch
of these let's just plot all of those ok
so it's good there why is this doing
that
oh maybe that will work let's try it now
there we go okay so that's plotting now
multiple variables there um just for fun
I could take this and I could say just
show me the actual equations that you're
solving in this very simple case um and
okay so in this simple case there are
only a few equations in the case of that
excavator arm there were six thousand
equations um and
um okay by the way um someone's asking
here about private blockchain ledger
with Wolfram language the answer is if
you have a private cloud absolutely if
you we I believe we have some
information about how to set this up now
it's a little bit complicated because
setting up the we're not if you have the
packaged private cloud you will have the
stuff to have a private blockchain but
if you want to do it like on your own
computer that's a significantly more
complicated proposition sorry we're not
solving that problem yet um but what we
can show you is some just do here um
here's actually what I wanted to show
you there is a new type of documentation
that are called workflows um
and I wonder whether we yet have the
workflows about okay no we don't yet to
have workflows about block chains
so right with respect to our public
blockchain our our public Wolfram
blockchain you pay for that with were
called service credits and well it's
super cheap compared to Bitcoin given
that we just saw that Bitcoin was
costing $12 per transaction there um
you
let's see so let me let me show you a
few more things which are new in eleven
point three um and let's go back here so
I can go back and look at my crib sheet
of so I know what I'm forgetting oh yeah
let me show you um talking of me show
you a completely different kind of thing
this is this is sort of in the in the
department of data that you can a lot of
second here
um data that you can get in Wolfram
language so this is now data about your
computer so if you say system process
data what you will see is that's the
processes running on my machine there
are 215 processes running on my machine
so for example I might say let's look at
memory usage here so this is now all
computable so we can say all this comma
memory and this will tell us humming the
process on my machine is using and for
example I could say make me a histogram
of that see if this works
um there we go so that's showing me a
histogram of the amount of memory used
per process on my machine actually one
thing I'm curious about is can I make a
graph that shows what process calls what
other process so if I take this system
process data there 997 and I say give me
all comma PID
therefore the process ID and actually
let's do PPID comma PID okay so this is
now gonna give me hopefully all pairs
okay very good that gave me the pairs so
now let me just take that make that a
normal expression okay so now what I
want to do is for each of those I want
to take the values and now I'm gonna
make this into a graph okay values there
and now what I want to do is I'm gonna
do something um um let's take those ooh
there's some missing key absent things
okay well let's not worry about those
for a second let's go ahead and say
apply rule to that okay so now we've got
um basically a bunch of rules that say
how processes what the parent process ID
was going to be actual process ID so now
let me make a graph so this is now
showing me a graph of what processes so
that's probably be PID one is let's do
this
just saying um vertex labels arrow
automatic it's gonna make a bit of a
mess probably okay so there's the that's
showing me all the processes on my
computer that okay so what this is
showing me P PID one is spawning lots
and lots of these processors but there
are some weird ones like process ID 426
is some kind of marooned process not
connected to PB ID one so that's an
example of something that sort of a new
kind of data that we can deal with here
let's try it let's try something
different let's try something really
outrageous um let's see someone's asking
when will eleven point three be
available to download I believe it is
available as of today so go right ahead
you can also use it in the cloud um and
but yep it should be available today
um and okay let me show you something
else this is another weird thing so this
is something where I can say network
packet recording so let me go ahead and
record point one seconds of network
packets on the network of my computer so
this is now recording from my very kind
of low level but these are network
packets and so let's take a look here at
so this is 67 packets were exchanged
through the en 0 interface of my
computer
and so for example let's say I go to I'm
actually curious what the packet types
were here let me see let me just see how
do I get that let's try and figure out
let me see what would be the packet type
Ethernet packets but what let's look at
one of these um
ah there we go okay so that is a TCP
packet and that is showing what actual
ports so I don't know what um let me see
what happens if I taste TCP port
oh that's it that is a moment I want to
say port 443 I doesn't know what that is
um ah okay but what that's what that's
showing me is a reuleaux level packet
what I thought I might find here is
packets oh yeah there we go there we go
okay that packet is me talking to you
that's a UDP packet and that's almost
certainly a UDP packet that is going out
that it's taking audio or might be UDP
packet from my screen actually if I
wanted to if I really want to sort of
live dangerously I could um copy data to
clipboard I can go ahead there's the
actual byte array um so let's say I mean
I don't know what I need to do here but
but um that's the actual sequence of
bytes in that UDP packet that was
transmitting some piece of audio or
transmitting some piece of my screen
actually if I wanted to just for fun let
me audio let me just capture some audio
um so I can talk to you here I think
that this is gonna capture audio from
the right microphone but we'll find out
okay so let's go ahead hello hello hello
okay let me say something here
okay four lucky that will have captured
the audio let me see um that is not a
good sign that suggests that the audio
input device is not the device that I'm
talking to you from oh well so much for
me showing you a bunch of new audio
tricks um
the
um oh I wanted to say somebody was
asking about download I should say that
if you are at a company or university
that has a site license for Mathematica
and Wolfram products it may not yet be
available through your site
administrator but it will be available
by Monday
um okay anyway going back here um let's
talk about some other other pieces of
new functionality oh well there's some
there's some very practically oh yeah
this is an interesting one
there's an interesting one that I
probably can't demo to you which is
external language sells so I just um so
here I'm I'm typing in - fascinating
um I'm I just created a Python cell
there and I just evaluated that in
Python and I'm afraid I'm I don't know
Python so I don't know whether I can if
I do something like this
I think that's not power I think that's
bit X or or something like that because
mere result but I could take a big lump
of Python code and just paste it in here
and and then just evaluate it in the in
the system um I don't know what um
oh boy I'm really embarrassing myself
though because I really do not know
Python so let's see whether I can I'm
just gonna guess something here does
this work anything like that no syntax
error so it goes well just proves I
don't know what I I you ask me well from
language I can do that very well but
Python I cannot um
another another thing we have so we have
an external evaluate function which can
evaluate things in Python or JavaScript
soon or lots of other languages a new
thing is being able to do basically
remote control a web a web browser so I
can say external evaluate webdriver
Chrome let me go ahead and look at the
documentation for this and now I can go
there are various external evaluator
types so here for example I can go to
Chrome okay external evaluate usage okay
so these are different commands that I
can go so I can say open web page so I
think what I do here is I can say open
web page arrow and I assume I have to
say HTTP wolf comm um and let's see what
happens
magically
magically chrome will open somewhere the
only question is where um ah
is that it no um
that is hard okay so somewhere probably
on my screen unfindable to me chrome
opened a web page but let's see what
happens if I say I think I can do
capture web page see what this does
there we go that was cool wasn't it so
there what I did was I remote-controlled
Chrome I told it to open that webpage
that gave null and then I said go
capture that webpage and it gave that
result okay so um
let's see um people are asking here
it's telling me that power and python is
wedge wedge so let's try that
I mean star star so let's try that okay
works and it reads back the big name
even um okay you're asking if we can
connect to a node.js server the answer
is yes if we go here you can pick nodejs
okay what's power in JavaScript let's
try the same thing he says
oh that sounds for
let's see whether I can maybe I don't
have no js' installed okay then I might
have to use the system install function
to install nodejs so again you know if
you're out of our ecosystem it's a
little bit out of your kind of escaping
from the beautifully beautiful garden
that we have built um okay well so I
don't seem to have no jazz installed
here um but the idea is you can use
nodejs if you installed it
um someone is asking about our actually
we have had a very sophisticated our
link package for many years now this is
so that allows you to do all kinds of
things um I have to admit that I'm not
an expert in using it but it's a very
full-featured back and forth exchanging
data in both directions with our kind of
system um
someone is asking about MATLAB I have no
idea I don't know whether they have any
of the kinds of modern protocols that
you need to be able to do these kinds of
connections I also have no idea whether
their license agreements allow these
types of connections um
someone is asking can we do sheet music
OCR not as a built-in thing that would
be an interesting thing to try and train
the system to do we've done a whole lot
of experiments on math OCR people have
built some fairly nice math OCR systems
using our technology sheet music would
be an obvious cool thing to try um and
should it should be a really good thing
to to try out all right let me go back
here um to you see where I was
yeah
back oh yeah here this may be no fun I I
I wonder with a speech synthesized well
here actually I could do speech
synthesized that would give me a
waveform actually um okay
let's do
and celebration of the fact that it's
2001 s 50th anniversary coming up in
about a month let's try doing this and
that should give us an audio object that
now oh you know what I maybe was just
doing the wrong thing before I wasn't an
idiot I was I was doing the wrong thing
I think my audio capture may have worked
just fine
um so here let me pause this um now I
could do for example for this so this is
now streaming audio this is now
synthesized the audio for open the pod
bay doors and now I could do spectrogram
of that okay there we go
now I'm curious if I do an audio capture
and I can channel poor Dave there open
the pod bay doors okay now let's do a
spectrogram of that and there's my
spectrogram um and it's interesting
actually my spectrogram is much lower
frequency than this one maybe I should
have picked a different voice but one of
the things we actually have a now is an
audio distance function and I have to
admit I have not used it but let me see
um
[Music]
see
this is some because we have the ability
to take these things in encode them I
mean I could do a net encode of this
audio and I would get something that
could be fed to a neural net um
okay so
someone is asking the idea is to use
whorfin language to do computations send
the results to a node.js server um
Sandara
results to a node.js service so I think
I think it's really easy to do that
right I mean all you would say is if
you've got a URL you would say
you would just send something to that
URL and in fact if I say let's do this
let's say URL read from HTTP slash slash
Wharton com
and I think what I'll get back is an
HTTP response object so for example I
could take that response object and I
can now dig into it and I can ask for
the headers for example and that will
now be the header of my HTTP response
object I could if I wanted to I could
build I could say generate HTTP response
if I were going so let's say I am going
to prove what could I do
um I don't know what happens if I just
say 1 2 3 here okay
so that generate an HTTP response I
can't imagine what's in the HTTP
response let's look at its body ok its
body is probably the string 1 2 3
but that HTTP response I could now send
um to a I could say URL execute how
would I do this I want to send that HTTP
yeah I'm sorry but I really want that
was generating HP response I want to
send an HTTP request to a particular
place um oh let me show you a very
important new new thing in eleven point
three by the way okay this is actually
two major cool new things um
[Music]
dude
to text here not yet but it is coming
very soon the we've been building up to
having neural nets that we can get to
new speech to text and even as we speak
neural nets are being trained to do
exactly that um so we will have that
what about spiking neural nets in a
future version I actually don't know
what spiking neural nets are um so sorry
I don't know um okay here's a here's a
major new thing which I'm not sure how
well I'm gonna be able to do because I
may not I may be very lonely doing this
um this is a new piece of functionality
for doing chat now I'm gonna see whether
I can get I am going to let's see I'm
going to see whether this person is able
to chat with me
okay so I'm asking so this is now a
Wolfram language chat notebook and I
have no idea whether whether I'm sort of
hoping because that's one of the people
who's helping manage the live stream
this evening and I'm hoping that they
are there say hello there
and it'll now send that maybe I can say
that is a really bad sign not saying
that I did not have permission to go to
that chat location so this is using a
channel broker hmm that's very odd well
let's try maybe that's because it wasn't
an accepted chat yet let's view the
participants in this chat channel is
unavailable
humph alright let's try a new chat then
alright let's try the same person again
chat
participants will be in
- this chat after your first message
okay alright so let's say hello
right
I'll try
huh say miss you how odd
well okay so much for that chat anyway
the what's it what's interesting about
this chat is that well you can use it to
to send code back and forth it will send
arbitrary whorfin language expressions
although it's carefully sandbox so that
you can't basically send somebody a code
bomb um but you know if you have like a
classroom and you have a bunch of
students and you say when you've got an
answer send it in the chat you can
accumulate all of the chat answers in an
easy way okay so let's see um the let me
show you another major new thing which
is what we call presenter tools so this
is a way of making presentations in
Wolfram language um so I can pick let's
pick up some theming colors let's pick
kind of no let's pick to pick those
colors there
what did I pick here ago um and now I
will create a presentation all right and
what happens here so let's let's say my
title is this is my title okay so down
here I actually picked it to show
something with some sample so you know
what I'm gonna go back and and redo this
because I want to I want to show you
something with a blank um blank screen
so let's say new presenter notebook and
let's pick let's pick that type
let's pick let's change the theme colors
to those let's say that's not pre-fill
the slides with sample content that
would be a preview and let's now do a
create um if someone's asking how do I
bring up the chat dialogue um it's in
it's under the file menu so at the
bottom of the file menu um there's also
a palette um that I think there's a
palette maybe there isn't a palette no
the okay so bring it up from under the
the the file menu okay so I'm now going
to create a presentation here it's a
blank presentation and so now let me put
in here is my title
and let's put an a.m. I'll put in a
subtitle um that was I guess that's my
okay and let's go down here and let's
start now I want to say okay there's
gonna be my subtitle here um and now let
me make a new slide so I say instead
make a new slide so let's put in
something like let's put in a manipulate
here let's say manipulate um I don't
know sine X plus sine ax oops let's say
make a plot there
and X goes from zero to ten let's say a
goes from one to five for example okay
so now I've got a nice plot there um
which I can manipulate around here and
now maybe I put in something um well
let's just let's just put these in okay
um all right so now I want to make this
as a presentation okay
so let's just say start presentation and
now this will go fullscreen and here's
my presentation now notice that if I
have a smaller screen so now I can go to
the next page I think I press page down
by default and here we go now this is
the next page of my presentation and
it's all live so this is not it's not
PowerPoint anymore um and I can go and
just type into the cell and I can go do
computations here so I might have a
thousand factorial and we'll scroll
probably um and so this is now a
scrolling and I could go page up and
I'll go back to my previous slide okay
go to that little control there and I
can say and presentation um and now what
I'll find is that the things I computed
that was a big brother big thing to
compute but um the things I computed
right there I'm back from my
presentation so for example if I wanted
to I could add to myself a how do I do
this at this place light up I know what
I want to do I want to add so this shows
that I have not yet used this very much
how do I add a note that's window
elements come on now display slider
Oh shows slide notes okay all right but
now what I want to do is I want to add a
slide notes
doesn't contain any slide notes okay
well that's what I'm good
what do I want to do here set a cell
alignment
I think I'm being hung on my own numb
thing yeah where do I put in a slide
note
there's all sorts of stuff about
formatting
the
um
I go here let's see I want
maybe I go to yeah I'm actually I'm
actually embarrassed ly confused clear
format saying okay increase font size
that's all well and good
those are nice features but where is oh
maybe I want presentation controls how
about that no that's that tells me
whether I'm using page up page down etc
um the UM
you know I'm very confused by there
sorry about that anyway it's a cool
feature that you can put little notes to
yourself in here and they show up on a
secondary screen um when you're actually
running the presentation but but the big
deal here is that that if you um you
know I could take one of these for
example I could take let's just take
this um
and I can put that let's put that on a
slide new slide put that in here and now
when I do the presentation Oh
I go okay when I do the presentation um
it will it will appropriately-sized all
these things for my screen um so I can
do and if I had a little slide clicker
it would do that um and it's all set up
to be I wonder if I can simulate let's
see if I can do that
um see if I can simulate having a
smaller screen um go back to the first
slide okay see what happens yeah isn't
that cool right so I'm simulating having
a smaller screen and you're seeing that
the fonts are changing size and all that
kind of thing
um and similarly here I would hope if I
change size look at that isn't that nice
so wherever you're projecting this it's
going to do exactly the right thing
super-small
the
um
let's see someone's asking is there a
planned for um
doing math recognized like text
recognized yet probably someone's asking
about math pics calm yeah they use our
API actually further for their actual
computation it looked like a pretty nice
math OCR system um the
um let's see someone is asking how is
the compiler rewrite coming along very
well actually I can't demo it right now
probably but um if you watch some of the
live streams coming up in the next few
weeks you'll probably see some some
pretty cool stuff happening with the
LLVM compilation okay somebody invited
me to chat but see what happens if I
accept the chat um
okay have a go well let's see whether
this works let me see if I can send
let's see if I can send that graphic
over
which I don't want an employed cell you
just want to paste that graphic and I
want to say send um and hopefully I
manage to send that graphic over maybe I
can send actually tell you what let me
send the actual let me send the whole
manipulate just for see this is really
very exotic what I'm doing I'm taking
something out of a slideshow that I was
just presenting and I'm putting it in
chat and I'm gonna send a live object in
chat and let's see whether Danielle can
send back the live object with the
slider moved to a different position
then I'll be impressed I've um I've
never I don't know
[Music]
um
so is it all turn to descend okay let's
see are we gonna get this back um
no am i chatting to myself again
maybe I am okay let's see what have I
forgotten to show you boys some huge
function I've forgotten to show you um
that's not I wanted there see um oops
okay let me try to remember whether
whether I'm missing something
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah there's if people
are interested in mathy things um oh
yeah let me show you a few bits and
pieces that are just sort of decorative
in a sense um let's do let's say I
wanted to do audio here um you'll notice
if I close this up I now get a little
opener there I find that convenient cuz
sometimes I don't notice the closing of
cells on the right hand side um there
are some oh yeah here's another
important thing yes let me show you
something that's kind of useful so let's
say I am typing in something like I just
say you know range of 30 and I just want
I'm gonna say that plus 1 well okay
let's say I have that whole thing and
I'm gonna say that plus 1 but that's a
big long input and I don't want people
to have to see that whole big long input
so maybe I take that and I can right
click here and I can say I can eyes that
and it turns into this just little
iconic thing that it still evaluates
it's still as far as as far as the
actual computation is concerned it still
is that list but the point is that it is
showing in iconic form there so for
example if I were to take let's say I
make a plot of um I don't know what you
know some function X - 10 - 10
um and I say you know filling arrow axis
filling style arrow yellow all those
kinds of things let's let's say I have a
whole bunch of those those those some
options that
okay there it is but let's say that I'm
I want to not have to have people see
those options well I can just I can eyes
those options and then all they say is
that and now it will still evaluate the
same and people if they're interested
can go in and look at what those options
were but you don't have to see the
options if you don't want to so that's a
that's a nice feature
um the another thing this is very it's
kind of geeky the curie function um so
this is a function that if I say Curie F
comma two XY it will be able to collect
those arguments this is sort of a a
combinators etc play it's kind of nice
because it a lot it prevents you it
avoids you needing to define explicit
function functions all right let me show
you a few other more sophisticated
Mathieu things okay let me show you
something which I thought was going to
be completely trivial so this is a
something for dealing with equations so
let's say we say 2x equals four and we
say divide sides comma two then it says
it's equal to 2 right and so this is and
let's say you say comma a here okay oh
that was a little tricky it had to be a
little clever there so this is like not
making the mistake of the elementary
student and this is saying 2x equals 4
great you can divide by a but if a is
not equal to zero you get this but if if
if otherwise
a is equal to zero you can't divide by
that and it's still true that two x
equals four there so this is this is
just and I'm sure if we do an inequality
here things will get even funkier and we
could say let's say divide sides I
wonder what happens if we do this work
no we can't divide sides
that's all terms have equal nonzero
signs okay so that's I see that that's
because a is equal to 3 it nodes it can
just do that division so this is an
interesting thing because it allows one
to essentially build up as a proof
sequence by 4/4 algebra by just doing
this um and
it's some
okay somebody is saying for easiest
cases it would be nice if you could name
icon eyes whatever you want
let me answer a couple questions here um
the okay hold on several different
things
Oh somebody said they and see the chat
quite what I'd intended but yeah okay
fine yes so you moved it back to another
zero and then you pasted the results how
to enter chat yeah so so we can chat
back and forth arbitrary whorfin
language expressions um okay let's see
um
personal scientific note-taking you know
I use I have probably by now hundreds of
thousands to millions of notebooks that
I have used precisely for personal
scientific note-taking in um maybe for
that particular purpose maybe tens of
thousands you know this is exactly what
I do I mean you know it's it's um oops
that was over there I didn't mean it
over there but I meant over here you
know here's a heading I start tightening
things n hello there maybe I want to put
in some math e stuff I put you know
x-squared there you know divided by X
plus 3 etc etcetera etcetera
and I can do all of my and if I you know
I find whenever I'm trying to like
organize pictures or something I always
find like if I drag a picture from
somewhere I always find it easier to
drag pictures into into an often
notebook than then pretty much anything
else and what's really cool now is you
can take these notebooks and you can
just publish them into the cloud and you
can go on using them in the cloud you
can give other people access to them and
so on actually I have to show you one
thing given that I showed this picture
so that's a bitmap but there's a
function image graphics which just got a
lot better in version 11.3 which tries
to take that see what it did it tries to
take them it tries to turn that into
vector graphics so you'll see that this
thing was a bitmap if I make it bigger
that was a nasty bitmap and but yet here
this is using a bunch of techniques to
basically turn that into a and so now if
I wanted to I could actually treat that
as a polygon so I could say for example
actually what I could do let's try doing
this
let's try living dangerously again and
let's say image region and that should
try to turn it into a region object and
it didn't because I probably need to say
binarize first because it probably only
does that for
things uh let's see when in doubt read
the documentation oh not the right thing
that's not what I wanted I wanted
instead
oh yes now I just wanted the graphic
here and then I wanted to say I want to
say what did I want to say I wanted to
turn that into a region so I wanted to
say discretize
folks I believe of that graphic and that
should turn this if I'm lucky into
it's obviously very big here it should
turn it into a computable region but I
can then do computational geometry on um
it's probably probably trying to do this
at very high resolution um come on wake
up
uh my gosh what is it doing
you know when in doubt
just see I think I probably gum this up
with all kinds of stuff that's what I
get for trying to demo everything at the
same time um
just try doing this let's try okay wake
up thing alright I'm actually going to
try just starting a new desktop umm and
[Music]
try that same thing again when I don't
have all kinds of weird dynamic chat
sessions running and God knows what else
so see something is running very very
very slowly on my computer you know what
I need to do to figure that out I need
to run that system processes command and
figure out but let's just try this here
um so this comes back in reasonable time
or not as the case may be um okay well
maybe this is really hard for some
reason
okay so let me answer a few other
questions people had here um I saw a
rapper connectible from language to open
AI Jim
yes reinforcement learning actually in
inversion 11.3 we're starting to have
some of the things that you need for
that in particular we have this has been
a big mistake whatever I was doing here
in particular we have a function called
net state which is a way of representing
the internal state of
of a neural nut
what is this doing to me this is really
odd and my computer is running really
slowly which makes me suspicious that
something something untoward is
happening here but let's try this again
and you know what I mean
when in doubt use one's own tools so let
me go ahead and just signing into the
cloud for me there um let me go ahead
and try and use system processes system
process data um and let's see what I can
do here and let's find out let's do a
sort by on that by let's just do a sort
by memory usage so sort by
um in there let's say memory see if that
works okay oops I should have done a
reverse sort by let's go to the end here
six gigabytes male is using six
gigabytes what an outrageously corpulent
creature oh my gosh what's the world
coming to woman's male program uses six
gigabytes um
actually talking of which I can show you
but I probably can't show you this live
one of the new things is connecting live
to an IMAP server and I could actually
go and start processing my mail live but
I'm not gonna live that dangerously um
and and do that um there's there's
limits to the limits to transparency and
processing mail I haven't even looked at
is probably not some not a great idea
here um but okay so so I can I could
actually let me go ahead and and look at
system time let me sort by system time
here
um just see what
and I should have done a reverse on that
you
ah well that's interesting zoom which is
part of the framework that's you being
used to transmit this live stream is
using tons of using tons of CPU time so
it goes ok question that came next ok so
I was just looking at net state owned at
state object here we go that's what I
want um this is a new thing that allows
one to basically store recurrent states
and update them um
to have a Python cell which can run
Python without using the string so
let's see what do you mean without using
the string so so you can say external
evaluate if I say external evaluate um
Python , and then I say you know 34 to
the power 6 or something then that will
run that just runs Python like that um
if I want to call this is doing it as a
piece of the notebook here and you can
have a big lump of python code in here
if you want to and we do a pretty good
job of converting data types and so for
example if you set if you want to get an
image back you set a Python variable you
can go ask the value of that but you get
the file and you can go import that and
so on um ok next see use cases
preliminary quantum computer
stuff to play with an eleven point three
point one don't know if it'll be
available there we have been building a
sort of standardized quantum computing
package that's coming along very nicely
actually
um I don't know exactly when it will be
ready um
somebody's keen on curry good glad you
like it it's some the full version of
curry is kind of it was kind of
difficult to design and the full curry
allows all sorts of elaborate kinds of
ways to reorder its arguments and so on
the default which we organized about for
a long time is what should curry of f
actually just do and what curry of f
does is it curries like that it's the
second it pulls the second argument in
the first place because that's the most
common thing you actually need so if I
say curry find a derivative like this
then what it's going to do is that will
be just a a currying thing which I can
now apply to something like X to the
sixth and then that becomes a curried
form of D that I can then apply to X to
the six okay
um stylus input we haven't done that yet
um you know one of the things that that
happens is um if I were to bring up so I
could deploy oops I don't have my iPad
here oh well um if I if I were to deploy
a form function um what can I show you
here let me show you something um I'm
going to if I'm lucky I have an iPad at
my bag here um I'm a second this is some
okay I have an iPad Mini let's see what
happens here
um all right so what I'm going to try to
show you is
and I probably
like this end because it seems to have
almost no power
okay well I'm gonna show you let me set
up my um
camera here and something if you haven't
seen it um definitely worth seeing set
up a camera
and I could use I could just use dynamic
of current image but let me use a just a
standard camera here
there we go I gotta use the the white
pad of paper behind the iPad trick um to
not have it to wash out like that let's
see um
that's uh okay let me make it a little
bigger on the screen and then I will
show you what I was trying to show you
okay so there's my iPad come on focus
camera focus how do you do that do I
press a button here on the camera and
what does that - does that focus it
somewhat magnificent okay this is
Wolfram player and it plays notebooks
that it can find in the cloud and so if
I go here this is this is actually
running locally on the iPad this is
running the the Wolfram engine locally
on the iPad so for example here's a
manipulate so I can go and scroll
through this here's I manipulate um and
I can go and do computations with the
manipulate directly on the iPad this is
pretty cool and basically what's
happening here is you're transferring
these notebooks well you can transfer
them in many different ways you can get
them from a cloud or if if you get sent
a notebook an email you can then just
immediately open it in this player app
and that's that's pretty nice um you can
also of course go um - I don't want to
go there I want to go there you can also
just go directly to the Wolfram cloud
and great it doesn't like my email
address or doesn't like I am login oh
well so it goes um the you can go
directly to the the cloud app and the
cloud app allows all kinds of input that
beyond just textual input and one of the
things we're looking at is allowing
stylus input for the for the cloud app
so then you will be able to just enter
things with it with the stylus that way
um
the yeah you can do the note-taking by
the way in in the cloud app just fine on
an iPad
let's see automatically time-stamped
entries actually you can get
automatically times down to entries um I
never do this but for example you can
get here if I go to the sell menu I can
go to notebook history and I can see the
history of everything I typed into the
notebook and you can actually get that
in computable form we're actually going
to be adding some more
computability to this and there is a way
to set every input line to give a
timestamp um I have not done that in
probably 28 years but I'm pretty sure
that if I go to this option inspector I
can find a thing that shows that C cell
labels cell labels um cell
so
options I'm sure it's in cell labels
I don't immediately know how to do this
spots Oh cell yeah it's somewhere in one
of these in one of these ridiculously
large number of options there is a way
to have it label every
[Music]
um I'm sorry I'm not gonna be able to
find this um I wonder what it's called
and it's called time stamp or something
anyway there's that there's a way to
label every cell with its time um
positions of words in a word cloud well
I think you can do some of that I'm not
sure how how well you can do it
um easier to find items on there more or
less alphabetical it's an interesting
idea it's an interesting idea should we
should look at that um
can I use minimize or maximize with a
GPU and a new option well let's see um
we should be using we should be making
serious use of GPUs through the
underlying libraries that we're using
certainly a neural net stuff which is
obviously doing minimization internally
we are absolutely using the latest GPU
technology that's supported through the
various libraries and hardware systems
and the Intel DNN system I believe we've
recently started using um
question here is is there automatic
conversion from Python pandas dataframes
to datasets
I'm not sure about that it's a
reasonable thing to ask I mean I don't
think I think data sets can have a lot
more in them um but going certainly that
way should work okay somebody is
suggesting that I look at cell tags I'm
gonna I'm just just to see whether I can
actually do this because I really don't
think I've looked at it in in and some
ridiculous amount of time but let's take
a look show-cell tags well fine but what
and it's cell tag yeah there's some way
of telling it to show cell tags and then
to make those cell tags be time stamps
um
okay well I think I'm almost going to
have to wrap up here but but um
is there any final questions I can try
and address those I think I've gone
through a decent number of things that
are new in oh I didn't show you these
this whole new documentation framework
um this is a documentation framework
that documents things that are not just
input-output kinds of things so it
documents things that involve perhaps
going to external programs and so on so
it's it's a new framework for
documentation that we've introduced and
we have lots of examples of that now for
doing all kinds of things let me see
yeah in terms of math um those
interested in that I think this is
somewhat more technical but um we have a
a nice new function that does asymptotic
analysis it's kind of a big deal from a
mathlete point of view that we're able
to do here's a differential equation
that has a small parameter in it and
we're able to do these asymptotic
expansions so if I try to do a power
series expansion we just got a bunch of
zeros probably here but this is now an
asymptotic expansion which has
traditionally been kind of a something
of a black art in the in mathematical
physics but now finally we've been able
to automate this and we've got some
functions that do it we could also do
things like if you're doing
computational complexity theory for
example you might want to say is
factorial asymptotically less than n to
the N okay and I think I have to say n
goes to infinity here
okay um and it says true and let's try
them just for fun I because I don't know
the answer is n n factorial to the N is
presumably not asymptotically less but
an factorial squared
oh it's also not as emphatically this
Wow
it's an factorials are like the 1.1
asymptotically less hmm I learn
something here let's try 1 plus 1 over n
up Bronx antics
that's still asymptotic with us I wonder
if I go one plus one over log N
huh interesting okay well anyway maybe
if that's decreasing at all it will be
asymptotically less but so those are
those are tricky sort of fine
calculations of working out growth rates
orders of growth and so on and making
hierarchies of orders of growth highly
relevant for a bunch of things in number
theory and in computational complexity
theory we've now automated those things
um the UM I think that's about it I'm
sure I've forgotten some very important
things and I'll um
[Music]
teams that work on all these things are
always proud of what they've done and
it's some I'd like to be able to show
off from um a lot of what's there but
I'm probably forgetting some some
important things but um I think um
that's um
that's probably about it I I did just
mention workflows I'm being reminded
about mentioning workflows um I did
mention those oh this is I mean for
those who are really aficionados this is
important this entity prefetch function
which sounds like it's kind of a trivial
thing is actually really important for
desktop usage because if I say something
like um tungsten density okay that will
query our knowledge base and it will
find the density of tungsten but what
will have happened when I asked for the
density of tungsten um the is it will
have almost certainly pre fetched the
densities of every chemical element so
if I say cometh garments here um so it
won't have to go let's see if I just say
density here I'm just gonna work yeah
okay so it it that came back
instantaneously it didn't have to query
the knowledgebase again to go find any
of those because it had prefetched these
because it is calculating it is guessing
that if I asked for the density of one
elements I'm likely to want to ask for
the densities of other elements um and
so it will do that that was why I was a
little surprised for people who hear a
lot earlier that interpreter is also
doing this kind of pre Fletch mechanism
but I think that the sizes of the towns
that we had to use was small enough that
it would have had to prefetch a hundred
thousand towns to get to the point where
it was doing that but it's got a bunch
of algorithms for figuring out what are
clusters of entities and clusters of
properties that tend to be requested
together and that's something that will
make a lot of things a lot faster um the
[Music]
let's see once the compiler could
rewrite gets closer to down the compile
function will the compiled functions be
more expansive in the set of functions
they can actually compile absolutely we
will be able to compile the whole
language basically and using all kinds
of callback mechanisms into the from a
runtime library into the core engine but
basically what will be done what is
being done is sort of a complete type
analysis and that's what that's the big
benefit of having a symbolic language is
that you can actually do sophisticated
type analysis directly using the
language itself and that's that's what's
happening and it's going to be really
cool and you're going to be able to get
things like standalone executables if
you're not using too much of the you'll
be able to get chunks of standalone and
executable you can run and all that kind
of thing
I should comment when you're doing
neuron that's right now you can already
get the material to make a standalone
executable um the
um yes so um Oh somebody is giving me
the proof of of what I was talking about
about n factorial and n to the end thank
you that's you that looks that looks
right um okay well thanks a lot for for
joining us have fun with version 11.3 if
you want to just play with it go to the
cloud and just start playing with the
cloud for the version on the cloud the
or download fee if you have access to
desktop version download that or by all
means buy a desktop version and then you
can use it to your heart's content
um oh somebody is asking um the
somebody's saying can you please help me
with a Python program for a class no I
don't know anything about it the person
who developed Python I think knew our
language before he started writing
designing Python knew that version one
of our language so I suspect there are
some similarities there but beyond that
I know virtual um and let's see somebody
is asking about rdf and sparkle we
actually have been working on a bunch of
things do without - sparkle they're not
ready yet
stay tuned watch some of our design
reviews and you'll see what we're
thinking about with without - Sparkle um
that all has to do with these things we
call entity stores let me not get
started talking about that that's that's
a way of representing sort of a
generalization of relational data in a
symbolic fashion but that's for another
time
okay well thank you all for for joining
me tonight and check out check out some
of our our internal software development
meetings if you're interested in seeing
how we figure out all this stuff okay
good night thanks